[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'erreur
de parler mon rêve de revoir toute
l'actu politique et parlementaire mais
l'auto du beau chant katia bonjour
michael est avec nous emmanuel rivière
bonjour vous êtes directeur de kantar
publique l'institut de sondage que l'on
ne présente plus on va revoir avec vous
les temps marquant de cette semaine avec
d'abord le grand chantier de l'été la
réforme du code du travail qui sera mise
en oeuvre par ordonnance le gouvernement
a dévoilé ses plans
l'exécutif qui a également présenté un
nouvel arsenal pour renforcer la
sécurité
face à la menace création d'une cellule
de riposte et puis dernier jour de
campagne pour les candidats à l'élection
législative focus à suivre sur la
première circonscription de l'eure avec
valérie brochard alors doute d'ailleurs
la première page de cette émission
consacrée aux élections législatives
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en juin prochain le palais bourbon va
faire peau neuve de nouveaux élus plutôt
novice en la matière a priori devraient
faire leur entrée dans l'hémicycle
portrait robot de cette nouvelle
assemblée avec stéphanie des pierres ces
législatives font souffler un vent de
nouveauté sur l'assemblée environ 40%
des députés sortants ne se représentent
pas à droite comme à gauche des figures
de la politique française ont décidé de
jeter l'épongé à cause de l'orage pour
des raisons personnelles ou encore parce
qu'ils sont touchés par la loi sur le
non-cumul des mandats et qu'ils ont
préféré garder leur mandat local
conséquence il y aura donc au moins 216
petit nouveau sur les bancs de
l'assemblée fin juin il y aura aussi
plus de femmes pour ces élections la
plupart des partis présentent presque
autant de femmes que d'hommes
sauf les républicains qui n'ont que 39%
de candidates et l'extrême droite 34%
nouvelles têtes mais aussi nouveau
mouvement la république en marche des
manuels macron devrait envoyer de très
nombreux députés au palais bourbon
il présente des candidats dans 525
circonscriptions sur 577 dont un tiers
de débutant en politique
l'émergence de ce nouveau mouvement
bouscule le traditionnel clivage gauche
droite des candidats officiellement
investi par l ère où le ps n'ont pas
l'étiquette de la république en marche
mais promettent quand même de soutenir
le président de la république au total
pour ce premier tour des législatives
7882 candidats sont en lice avec un
record dans deux circonscriptions il y à
26 candidats pour un seul fauteuil
emmanuel rivière voyons un petit peu
avec vous vos études d'opinion
concernant cette élection législative on
va vers le chamboule tout ça y est
certes pour gagner son pari mais cette
majorité absolue tout indique en marche
obtiendra une majorité des voix et en un
net écart avec les poursuivants
d'après les enquêtes un peu plus de 30%
31% dans la nôtre ce qui n'est pas que
le sale par rapport aux scores obtenus
par des majorités précédente parfois au
dessus de 40 en 2012 pour le parti
socialiste et ses alliés 34% mais qui
crée les conditions d'une majorité large
tout simplement parce que les autres
sont loin
arrières au tour voire en dessous de 20%
c'est encore nouveau dans le paysage
politique c'est très latine
traditionnelle soit si loin et c'est là
où on peut effectivement parler de
chamboule-tout c'est à dire qu'on a des
formations politiques ou des coalitions
qui bonhomme à lens entre les étiages où
les étiages bas aussi et entre 35 et 45
% des voix qui se rouvrent trouve
ramenée parce que en marche puissent
danser électorale à celui du parti
socialiste celui des républicains et
leurs alliés à autour de 20 %
c'est-à-dire à peu près le seuil de
qualification ce qui veut dire que le
candidat aux marches souvent pourrait se
retrouver au soir du premier tour seuls
en lice face à mal un seul opposant
justement c'est ce que vous avez prévu
le premier tour se tient dimanche il ya
quand même encore des surprises
possibles ce qui peut y avoir des
rectificatifs par rapport à l'image de
la nouvelle assemblée que vous nous
donnez là aujourd'hui on s'est risqué à
faire des projections en sièges qui
anticipent ce que pourrait être le
second tour en fonction ce que les
électeurs nous disent aujourd'hui être
leur report possible en cas de duel en
marge contre la droite ou contre on
contre la gauche et les sas
effectivement ça donne aujourd'hui un
très large score en nombre de députés à
en marche
simplement on a vu dans le passé ça a
été le cas en 2007 ça a été le cas un
petit peu en 2002 aussi qu'il pouvait y
avoir des petits correctifs
incontestablement il semble que les
électeurs est envie d'aller jusqu'au
bout de cette histoire cap dur et en
plus pas loin 5e république aux
chimistes une loi d'airain
alors qu'il vient contredire une autre
loi d'airain sur laquelle pour gagner
circonscription enfin les aides très
ancrée localement avoir eu des mandats
etc
là ça balaye à notre avis pour savoir
faire des mots bis qui vont être élus
m'enfin c'est pas totalement nouveau
mais ce correctif pour être lié au fait
que les gens se disant oui c'est acquis
la majorité a peut-être maintenant
et justement il ya aussi quelque chose
dont on parle souvent dont on dit que ce
sera un élément clé pour pour le scrutin
c'est l'abstention les sondeurs comme
vous ont prévu un niveau record
d'abstention pour ce premier tour est ce
que pour quoi elle serait démotivés
fataliste des sondeurs ont prévu un
niveau en travaux après ronde autres
nous notre dernier sondage donnerait une
participation supérieur à 60% ce qui
serait ce qui serait pas mal c'est très
difficile à anticiper
la participation sera qu'une logique
abstentionnistes on va voter pour
certains électeurs les plus assidus pour
la huitième fois en moins de 12 mois
il y a sur notre petit effet de
lassitude un coût d'entrée dans les
initiatives qui était important qu'en
tout comme vous l'avez cité on a parfois
plus de 20 candidats
et puis l'idée qu'il y aura pas beaucoup
de suspense c'est très démobilisateur
parallèlement je pense que les électeurs
et pas simplement les électeurs dans
marche cela france a soumis ceux du
front national ont bien expérimenté
aussi pendant ces derniers mois de le
pouvoir que l'on détient avec son
bulletin de vote sept se dégage isme qui
a été très opérant finalement les gens
se disent ça marche quand on a envie de
dire ça suffit
ceux qu'on a trouvés on les dégage ça
marche donc ça ça pourrait être un stand
lecteurs le vert les yeux moi je crois
qu'on aura la réponse dimanche à midi
plutôt à 17h sur le véritable taux de
participation alors emmanuel rivière
beaucoup de circonscriptions seront
passés à la loupe pour ce premier tour
on va s'intéresser à la première de
l'essonne c'est bien la première de
l'essonne où la bataille s'annonce
difficile pour manuel valls notamment
reportage de yann plantier et valérie
brochard il refuse toutes les caméras et
pourtant il est dans toutes les têtes
manuel valls l'ancien premier ministre
n'est pas investie par le parti
socialiste ni par la république en
marche
ces deux parties ont décidé de ne pas
lui opposer de candidat pourtant ils
sont nombreux à se revendiquer de la
majorité présidentielle quelques jours
avant mon investiture manuel valls a
fait pression sur emmanuel macron pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de candidat face à lui
les militants de la circonscription ont
décidé
malgré tout de maintenir ma candidature
l'oni manuel valls ni les autres
candidats l'ont prouvé qu'ils étaient
avec ma compte pour être adhérent d'un
match
il suffit de cliquer un bouton ils ont
juste cliquer et moi j'ai fait le
travail sur le terrain
au total 22 candidats se présentent dans
cette 1re circonscription est celle qui
semble la mieux placée d'après le
dernier sondage ifop
c'est farid amrani la représentante de
la france insoumise créditée de 26% au
premier tour elle garde la tête froide
aujourd'hui son nom un quartier si on
est sur le terrain c'est aussi pour
inciter les gens à aller voter parce que
plus l'abstention sera importante plus
manuel valls nous au passé alors c'est
manuel valls votre adversaire principal
en tout cas c'est la politique qui met
en péril a mis en place jusqu'à présent
qui nous pose problème pour autant la
candidate ne veut pas faire de l'anti
valls son argument principal nous n'est
pas là que pour dégager manuel valls on
est aussi pour porter un projet c'est ce
qu'on la sp quand on nous dit voilà on
aimerait que vous puissiez passer etc
on leur dit mais nous ce qu'on veut
c'est que vous adhérez à notre projet
aussi côté les républicains une présence
au second tour s'annonce difficile
caroline varin redoute l'enracinement de
l'ancien premier ministre
farred quelqu'un qui est extrêmement
bien implantés sur le territoire voilà
il a un énorme réseau manuel valls donc
je pense qu'il travaille ses réseaux
c'est voilà mais sur le terrain lorsque
vous venez avec nous sur le terrain oui
c'est évident qu'à une forme de dégager
face à l'émiettement des candidatures
auquel il participe
le suppléant du candidat du mouvement
100% la force écocitoyenne craint la
victoire de l'ancien premier ministre
la majorité des électeurs de la première
circonscription qui ne peuvent plus voir
manuel valls en peinture veulent le
dégager tout est organisé pour que
monsieur balle soit élu et donc on va
arriver à ce paradoxe hallucinant qui
est que monsieur valls va se trouvait
donc le député d'une circonscription
dans laquelle il pourra même pas
circuler et pourra même pas circuler
dans la rue parce que les gens vont lui
cracher à la gueule et lui balancer des
pierres pour le moment manuel valls mène
une campagne très discrète résultats du
premier tour dimanche prochain
et on retrouve sur ce plateau valérie
brochard bonjour bonjour donc réalisé ce
reportage à khiam plantier vous arrivez
de de près vous prenez le tout cette
circonscription une question simple est
ce que vous avez pu apercevoir manuel
valls absolument pas absolument pas
manuel valls est vraiment le candidat
invisible nous sommes restés deux jours
avec yann plantier dans la
circonscription dans cette 1re
circonscription de l'essonne aux
tarterets aux pyramides à evry à corbeil
partout on est même allé du côté de
saint rémy les chevreuse parce que
francis lalanne venait à aider un
soutenir en tout cas un candidat dans
cet autre circonscription de l'essonne
personne pas même un militant difficile
de trouver même des tracts sur voilà sur
vous savez n'est dans les boîtes aux
lettres quand on se balade un petit peu
dans la rue
manuel valls c'est vraiment le candidat
invisible nous avons évidemment vous
l'imaginez bien contacter son service de
com pour essayer de le rencontrer pour
mettre en place un rendez vous on nous a
tout simplement répondu qu'il ne
souhaitait pas être suivi oui vous
simplement tout misé sur le local ça
peut peut-être se comprendre également
quand on a été victime certainement très
médiatique comme il l'a été absolument
et pour autant ce qui est assez
intéressant d'après donc le sondage dont
on s'est servi sur lequel on s'appuie en
tout cas pour ce reportage qui est donc
le sondage ifop qui est sorti dans le
jdd c'est qu'il serait quand même
crédité de 30% au second tour il
passerait au second tour ce qui est
assez impressionnant assez particulier
30% pourquoi parce qu'une implantation
locale parce qu'il masque ancien maire
d'evry avec voilà les gens sont quand
même on était plus ou moins content de
son travail réalisé localement mais sur
le terrain c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'on
entend quand même de lentilles valls
emmanuel rivière 30 % manuel valls
crédité de 30% temps du grand portage
une forme de violence incroyable mais là
on est vraiment dans le conflit entre la
force de l'implantation locale ancrage
la notoriété aussi normalement aide un
élu local à se faire élire et puis le
fait que manuel valls symbolise à lui
seul toutes les difficultés du parti
socialiste et une grande partie du rejet
de ce quinquennat
ce mouvement vert
forme de social libéralisme qui a été
voulu par françois hollande mais
extrêmement mal comprises par ses
électeurs probablement assez mal
expliquée et d'une certaine manière de
manuel valls est totalement cohérent par
rapport à la ligne qu'il a incarné en se
rapprochant des manuels macron
simplement voilà les électeurs sont si
sensibles aux trajectoires personnelles
au sentiment que ayant roulé au parti
socialise participer à la primaire il ya
une forme de retour
on l'entend on l'entend sur le terrain
on entend des mots comme trahison
clientélisme on en veut plus qu'il
dégage quel que soit finalement le très
violent assez verbalement en tout cas
c'est assez assez violent c'est
impressionnant de voir qu effectivement
dans l'histoire de cette présidentielle
c'est manuel valls qui aura finalement
eu davantage la figure du traître
oui qu emmanuel macron dont françois
hollande a pourtant glissé dans une
confidence il m'a trahi avec méthode
absolument
pour ce témoin emmanuel rivière ou
peut-être on peut faire un petit focus
également sur trois grandes
personnalités de l'élection
présidentielle qui se présente aux
législatives je prends de jean luc
mélenchon benoît hamon marine le pen
peut être un petit mot sur les sur les
chaussures chacun drogue de ses
candidats peut-être jean luc mélenchon à
marseille alors jean luc mélenchon il ya
là beaucoup mieux partir les enquêtes
réussissant son implantation dans un
complexe et pas facile c'est jamais très
facile d'aller à marseille quand on
n'est pas authentiquement marseillais
mais là on voit bien effectivement que
le fait du pour réussir son pari oui
parce que pour eux monsieur mennucci qui
est le député sortant socialiste de la
circonscription est pas un socialiste
très à droite
eh bien on a l'impression que les choses
sont extrêmement compliquées
malgré son ancrage jean luc mélenchon ça
peut marcher pour la france soumise
partout ailleurs c'est plus compliqué
plus compliqué notamment des gars du
fait que la france a soumises a eu du
mal à maintenir le flambeau de ce bon
premier tour pour de jean luc mélenchon
marie le pen et marine le pen elle la
situation qui semble assez favorable a
raté d'un cheveu il ya et il ya cinq ans
dans cette circonscription entre temps
et d'un moment était acquise au premier
tour pour le front national et les
choses sont assez engagé la grande
difficulté en fait c'est pour benoît
hamon
qui dans sa propre circonscription était
4e à la présidentielle attrape donc pour
lui si ce sera compliqué selon vous oui
d'ailleurs il anticipe un cette grande
difficulté pour le parti socialiste et
la question du positionnement du parti
socialiste dans cette élection liste il
est très difficiles à articuler
alors on va refermer un petit peu cette
page sur les élections législatives on a
parlé un petit peu du gouvernement et du
travail qu'il est en train de
s'effectuer on passe aux grands
chantiers de l'été la refonte du code du
travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et cette réforme du code du travail se
fera certainement sûrement pas
ordonnance avec un projet de loi
d'habilitation conseil des ministres qui
sera présenté le 28 juin prochain
les paires tonnerre sociaux seront
consultés mais la réforme soulève à vent
de fronde
regardez pas d'annoncé fracassante mais
une philosophie réaffirmé réformer le
droit du travail en concertation avec
les partenaires sociaux
j'entends certains parler de risques de
guerres sociales
la seule guerre sociale que je conduirai
c'est celle de la lutte contre le
chômage de masse objectif rassurer les
syndicats après la parution dans le
parisien d'un avant projet de loi
contenant des pistes jamais évoqué dans
les concertations
l'exécutif a depuis fait savoir que ce
texte n'émanait pas du gouvernement
edouard philippe donne son accord à des
concertations jusqu'à la fin de l'été
une volonté de dialogue apprécié chacun
des syndicats va être reçue six fois au
tour sur deux fois par sujet c'est pour
nous un bon point maintenant ce qui va
compter pour nous c'est pas tant la
méthode même si nous la salle au que
le fond des sujets qui vont être qui va
être abordée premier axe de négociations
le renforcement de l'accord d'entreprise
priorités du gouvernement mais des
points de crispation se dessine en
premier lieu le plafonnement des
indemnités prud'homales en cas de
licenciement abusif
du point de vue des salariés le fait
qu'ils aient pas de bahram isation le
résultat c'est que d'après nomme à
l'autre pour deux salariés qui ont le
même job qui elle-même poste qui ont la
même ancienneté qui ont le même âge et
bien ils vont avoir du simple au triple
on a des mythes et prud'homales est ce
que c'est juste ça ne me paraît pas
juste et nous colle aux demandes
c'est une des conditions c'est que le
juge puisse déroger dans des cas
particuliers
parce qu'on est bien sûr des
licenciements dits abusif ça veut dire
son cause réelle et sérieuse
on débat aussi la fusion des instances
représentatives du personnel et le
référendum d'entreprise à l'initiative
de l'employeur de nombreux points à
trancher avant la fin des concertations
prévue le 21 septembre sujet signé
vienne elle aura avec nous les devis de
fo pour parler justement de cette
méthode est un petit peu du fond quand
même de ce code du travail de cette
réforme
peut-être un mot sur la méthode du devis
qui passe mal où ça passe ça plutôt bien
commencé on a vu ça au début de la
semaine les syndicats étaient plutôt
contents que tous les sujets soient mis
sur la table qui est une concertation
finalement plus longue que ce qui avait
été envisagé par emmanuel manquons
pendant la campagne présidentielle
lorsqu'il dresse qui a tendu un petit
peu le climat sont les fuites dans la
presse
en tout la question c'est de savoir si
ce sont de simples fuite concentration à
être orchestrée ou pas et puis est ce
que ces fuites ont vocation à devenir
réalité ou est ce qu'il n'ya pas de plan
caché comme l'affirment la ministre du
travail mme muriel pénicaud donc le
début a été plutôt réussi mais ça peut
se crisper assez rapidement l'a bien
compris surtout ce qui intéresse les
syndicats on l'entendait dans le sujet
c'est le point d'aboutissement de la
réforme ok ça peut se crisper ou
concrètement ça peut se crisper
notamment sur les questions
qu'on a vu paraître dans ces fameux
suite et notamment sur l' équilibre de
ce qui pourrait être négociés au sein
des branches ou sein de l'entreprise
et parmi les chiffons rouges pour les
syndicats il ya notamment ce qui serait
la négociation des contrats de travail
au sein de l'entreprise avec
éventuellement aussi la négo
d'associations des motifs de rupture ça
ça fait partie des casus belli parce qu
il faut bien voir que on a bien compris
que la volonté du gouvernement s'étaient
finalement de trouver des accords au
plus près du terrain c'est à dire dans
l'entreprise la question c'est au delà
des grands thèmes qui ont été déclinées
cette semaine où est ce qu on place le
curseur est est-ce qu'on aboutit
finalement à une loi sociale libérale
avec plus de liberté pour les
entreprises mais plus de protections
pour les salariés
ou est-ce qu'on aboutit tout simplement
à une loi libérale qui qui qui qui
donnerait une prime à la compétitivité
est qui qui finalement détricoterait le
droit du travail
alors justement et mahdia driver à ce
qu'une loi libérale choc l'idéal tel que
le prévoit gouvernement sera soit bien
accueillie par l'opinion
les une grande ambiguïté sur cette
question la part des français qui on n'a
jamais cessé par toute cette campagne
bien avant de passer le chômage comme on
regarde leur priorité pour eux la
solution au chômage elles passent
probablement par une réforme il faut
changer un stock de règles ils sont nous
ce point de vue là c'est favorable à ce
qu'on réforme le droit du travail et
sous sensible à l'idée d'un
assouplissement
collectivement c'est comme ça qui se
représentent les choses mais à titre
individuel et non pas envie non plus de
se faire avoir ils ont fait un sentiment
que le rapport de force parce que le
chômage est élevé il est plutôt du côté
de l'employeur comme ça aussi que
résonnent et salariés c'est pour ça que
théoriquement il pouvait bien accueillir
certaines dispositions notamment la loi
travail de mejia mike comrie mais qu'ils
étaient assez solidaire avec ses
mouvements de résistance dans l'idée
qu'il fallait quand même maintenir un
certain nombre de protections le
comprend beaucoup l'exemple allemand
mais ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
qu'en allemagne il ya une tradition
syndicale très forte que ce soit au sein
des branches et des entreprises en
france aujourd'hui les syndicats sont
sont plutôt faibles et si on détricote
le droit du travail pour certes des
objectifs louables un plus de
compétitivité plus d'emplois et cetera
ça risque de mettre un moment donné le
salarié seul face aux chefs d'entreprise
et tous les salariés ne sont pas égaux
face à face aux patrons opel qu'il ya un
an
évidemment il y a
la loi travail qui était qui avait été
voté était notamment par les 49 3 on
s'en rappelle très bien et la rue avait
été extrêmement présente est ce que
cette fois on imagine encore une fois si
jamais il ya une forte majorité pour rm
dans d'or à nouveau la rue qui ont tant
de la rubrique ce thème là qu'est tout
ça c'est la confiance
quand vous êtes dans une société de
défiance vous ne vous dites pas que
l'assouplissement va générer des emplois
et donc de meilleures opportunités pour
ceux qui le perdent et vous ne vous
dites pas que le patron va pouvait des
accords locaux dans l'intérêt des
salariés on dit qu'il va essayer de
chercher à maximiser son intérêt que le
gouvernement va devoir je recherchais
cette conférence vous êtes en confiance
ce déclic qui lui permet de se dire oui
effectivement peut accepter de la
souplesse parce qu'il y aura des emplois
parce qu'on pourra se retourner si
jamais ça va mal dans telle ou telle
activité
et ça crée aussi la possibilité de se
dire les accords seront d accord
gagnant-gagnant dans les entreprises
mais cette clé elle est très important
c'est une clé symbolique qui n'a pas été
incarné par françois hollande dans son
quinquennat et tout le défi c'est la
folie pour emmanuel macron politiquement
par will ça va être une loi fondatrice
de son quinquennat 1 tout comme la loi
de moralisation de la vie politique ce
qui fait ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est qu'il n'y a pas d'état de grâce
pour emmanuel macron mais il ya une
sorte d'état de bienveillance et donc il
vient d'être élu les français sont prêts
majoritairement même s'il ya des
différences sur leur importance ou pas
lui accorder une majorité absolue voir
une majorité écrasante
les français sont prêts à lui donner sa
chance néanmoins vous en avez parlé tout
à l'heure des législatives même si
emmanuel macron obtient une majorité
très forte
sané qui vaudra pas un blanc-seing un
chèque en blanc de la part des français
et donc il faudra voir au final ce que
ce que ça donne à l'automne et c'est
pour ça qu emmanuel macron veut aller
très vite c'est parce que il sent bien
qu'il est temps qu'ils tant qu'il est
chaud et que procéder par ordonnance ça
évite finalement de perdre du temps et
de laisser vous êtes la mobilisation
difficile pakhtunkhwa oui il y aura il
peut y avoir un impact en fonction de
transit mais simplement il quand même
une différence fondamentale par rapport
à ces réactions électorale et puis la
réaction de la rue vous évoquez par
rapport à la loi y compris ses classes
étaient quand même clairement dans le
programmes des manuels macron est
tellement accroché à l'image à l'idée
qu'on soutenait de la volonté du projet
d' emmanuel macron ce n'était pas le cas
du quinquennat précédent
alors on va passer à l'autre grand
dossier de la semaine la sécurité avec
l'exécutif qui a présenté un nouvel
arsenal de sécurité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et un décret a été pris en conseil de
défense pour créer une task force
cellule opérationnelle
directement rattaché au président de la
république objectifs notamment
centraliser l'action des services de
renseignement explications avec ma été
frémont emmanuel macron en chef
d'orchestre du renseignement français
c'était l'une de ses promesses de
campagne la création d'un centre
national de contre terrorisme
cette task force sera placée sous
l'autorité directe du chef de l'état la
mission pour la vingtaine de personnes
mobilisés 24 heures sur 24 sera de
coordonner au niveau de l'elysée
la dgs scier la dgse à la tête de ce
dispositif
l'ancien numéro un de la direction de la
surveillance du territoire s'agit pas de
faire un service de plus il s'agit par
contre d'avoir une synthèse 24 heures
sur 24 de toutes les sources
d'information qui doivent remonter au
coordinateur national
donc on veut lui donner ces moyens
politiques ces moyens humains à charge
pour lui d'organiser au mieux cette ex
forces dans le même temps deux projets
de loi sont à l'étude
la prolongation de l'état d'urgence
jusqu'au 1er novembre et surtout en
texte qui inscrira les principales
mesures de cet état d'urgence dans le
droit commun parmi elles les
assignations à résidence ou encore les
perquisitions administrative un projet
de loi sera déposé avec un seul objectif
celui de renforcer notre arsenal
législatif de droit commun mais en
ciblant précisément l'objet qui doit
être l'objet de nos attentions la lutte
contre le terrorisme et en l'encadrant à
la fois dans la loi et à la fois dans le
contrôle du juge afin de pouvoir traiter
toutes les situations exceptionnelles ce
projet de loi sera présenté en conseil
des ministres le 21 juin prochain
autre projet du gouvernement renforcer
le plan vigipirate
alors cette taskforce conseil national
de contre terrorisme en français fait un
peu penser à ce qui existe déjà aux
états unis directement rattaché à la
maison blanche le dow vic faux est ce
que ce type de structure pas marché en
france est-ce que emmanuel macron prend
un risque politique en faisant ça que ça
marche c'est souhaitable
évidemment
après en terme de risque le plus grand
risque pour emmanuel macron sur le plan
de la sécurité comme sur le plan de
l'emploi
finalement ce serait de ce serait de ne
rien faire donc emmanuel macron il a
décidé d'agir de prendre les choses en
main y compris en matière de sécurité
la difficulté en matière de lutte contre
le terrorisme c'est que le risque zéro
n'existe pas donc effectivement emmanuel
macron il prend le risque de s'exposer
personnellement si on devait être
confronté malheureusement à de nouveaux
attentats après il faut se rappeler un
petit peu de la génèse de l'annnonce de
cette task force
emmanuel macron il a annoncé ça pendant
la campagne présidentielle à un moment
où ils avaient besoin de gagner des
points finalement sur le sur le régalien
et donc voilà maintenant qui est en
fonction il n'est en oeuvre cette mesure
l'objectif il est louable là encore
assez de mieux coordonner les services
de renseignement on verra si ça marche
ou pas mais ce sera de toute façon
difficile à évaluer puisque encore une
fois le risque zéro n'existe pas en
matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
ludovic le disait un pied sur la
sécurité à pied sur le doigt travail par
exemple
c'est ce qu'attendent les français
sécurité et sécurité d'emploi à côté du
chômage il est évident que dans le
contexte du vivant et j'en suis très
sensible à ce qui se passe au royaume
uni et une à dornes sur le thème la
sécurité notamment sur la lutte contre
le terrorisme et c'est un terrain plus
confortable même si c'est probable de
voir juger dessus non en fait il sera
davantage juger je pense sur les
réactions qu'il aura en cas d'attentât
et sur le sentiment que les français
auront qu on a fait le maximum
ou pas pour empêcher un attentat est ce
pour ça que c'est effectivement assez
confortable y compris d'avoir ce
durcissement et cesser ces mesures
extrajudiciaires qui sont envisagées
parce que beaucoup de gens raisonnent en
se posant la question est ce qu'on en
fait assez ou pas pour punir les
méchants et les empêcher de nuire alors
qu'en fait c'est comme vous le disais
tout à l'heure ludovic c'est une
question de curseur et quand on
une mesure si les dispositions pour
punir les méchants on s'expose à ce que
des gens qui n'ont rien fait soient eux
mêmes embêté quand on prend des mesures
extrajudiciaires les données qu'ils font
on s'expose aussi un risque politique
directe notamment pas si on reprend les
propos d' emmanuel macron d'il ya
quelques temps oui qu'il faudrait sortir
un jour de l'état d'urgence en même
temps on voit bien que dans le contexte
actuel et en cas de nouvel attentat les
les français pourrait finalement mal
réagir un con qu'on soit sorti de l'état
d'urgence c'est ce qui avait été annoncé
en juillet dernier par françois hollande
et puis le lendemain l'attentât de l'iss
dont évidemment au mois de novembre
puisque c'est le terme notamment de la
nouvelle prolongation de l'état
d'urgence on dansera à deux ans d'une
france où sous état d'urgence
alors ça perd de son efficacité disent
les spécialistes
au fil du temps mais pour finalement ne
pas prendre un risque politique trop
grand en sortant purement et simplement
de cet état d'urgence emmanuel macron
est en train parlant effectivement de
d'organiser la transposition dans le
droit commun d'une certain nombre de
d'un certain nombre de mesures qui
jusque là faisait partie de l'état
d'urgence et donc la question qui se
pose là effectivement c'est où on place
le curseur entre liberté et sécurité il
ya une grande demande de protection des
français bien évidemment mais on voit
bien que là encore le rebelle aurait bas
leur lot vous l'état d'urgence en lui
même sera sera prolongée dans un premier
temps et puis les mesures voulues par
emmanuel macron inscrits par l'assemblée
nationale parce qu'on en aura une oui il
y aura une large majorité la question
encore une fois elle est plus finalement
dans le débat il est plus dans la
société alors on voit bien que la gauche
notamment essayer de retrouver un peu de
la voix là dessus le débat il est plus
dans la société et on voit bien qu'il ya
des différences de vues entre les
magistrats qui sont assez critique sur
ces nouvelles mesures
et puis les forces de l'ordre qui sont
plutôt favorables dernier mais pour ce
qui est de l'opinion en tant que le
nombre de gens qui seront susceptibles
de perquisitionner oubliés de la nuit ou
assignés à résidence rafini tei mal par
rapport à la population et gras plutôt
du consensus le danger il est quand un
moment il ya un cafouillage révélé
médiatiquement au sein de la majorité
comme ça a été le cas sur la question de
la perte de nationalité la déchéance de
nationalité ou l'ass avait finalement
atteint espèce de consensus qui avait
sur les réactions au lendemain à
l'attentât du 13 novembre
merci emmanuel rivière ludovic vaut
d'avoir été l'invité les invités de
cette émission nous on se retrouve
dimanche pour une soirée spéciale
consacrée au premier tour de ces
élections législatives rester sur votre
antenne très 22 programmes campan
[Musique]